diese Paste hat mich durch meine
Studienzeit gebracht Teil 2 hier ist
alles was wir brauchen rote Paprika
gelbe Paprika Tortellini Ricotta
espinati Thunfisch und Kapern Olivenöl
auch ganz wichtig geben wir in die
Pfanne hinein Paprika lifehack anwenden
Eindrücken halbieren Strom raus Kerne
raus Paprika in die Pfanne geben
bisschen Salz dran und ein paar Kapern
der Welt wenn die Paprika fast gar ist
geben wir die Tortellini ins Wasser die
Tortellini sind so gut wie immer frisch
und brauchen deshalb nur zwei drei
Minuten Schlückchen Öl noch dran und
unseren Thunfisch einfach drauf einfach
unterrühren das ist alles was wir tun
müssen diese geruchskombination Paprika
Thunfisch dass meine Kindheit dass mein
Studium dass meine mama du bist meine
Mama soll das nicht so selten melde
jetzt können wir die Tortellini
rausnehmen zu unserer Soße dazugeben
vermengen das ganze jetzt spamen wir
noch Parmesan drauf probieren wir
das habe ich zu lange nicht gegessen